freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video einem ganz besonderen video mit
einem ganz besonderen gast ich habe hier
neben mir den anliegern gemisch stehen
und ich sage so viel wenn man hat es
drauf hat sternekoch du hast ein eigenes
restaurant in münchen und das hier ist
ein bett wo wir treten gegen einander an
das gibt mir auf jeden fall einiges zu
denken ist man könnte sogar meinen es
würde einigermaßen unfair zu gehen liegt
aber ganz falsch wenn wir nämlich jede
menge fähre zutaten mit denen wir eben
ein weihnachtsmenü kochen werden drei
gänge der sechs gericht eingestellt wer
play ablaufen glauben was heißt denn
fairer handel denn es geht um
gerechtigkeit es geht um lohn um bildung
und es geht um menschenrechte es geht
auch um klima also hier kochen wir haben
derzeit einen wollen spaß haben und ein
bisschen information noch nicht ausgeben
wir kochen auf jeden fall
eigenkreationen wir kannten diese ganzen
zutaten ich wir sind hier reingekommen
die wunderbare produktion hat sie uns
hingestellt und wir müssen jetzt gleich
uns überlegen was machen wir damit jeder
macht drei gänge sechs verschiedene
gerichte werden kreiert ja wir reden
schon viel zu lange wir sollten
eigentlich einfach loslegen ja
[Musik]
also ali los gehts wir fangen an mit dem
ersten gericht läutet was soll das hier
eigentlich werden ich habe so eine grobe
vorstellung habe mir die sache ein
bisschen angeschaut aber ich sage ganz
ehrlich was ich schon höre allein von da
drüben vom alle da geht er richtig
vollgas schon bis schon fertig mit den
nerven was
machst du denn mal lieber alle bürger
die ganze zeit noch ein geheimnis daraus
gemacht hier hinter der kamera ganz
ehrlich sagen ich weiß ist nicht also
ich fange jetzt erstmal mit den
süßkartoffeln an die dann dachte ich was
mit blumenkohl und limetten marinade und
wie könnten sie ja du bist schon fast
fertig weil ich guck doch mal lange
nicht fertig die süßkartoffeln die werde
jetzt schön langsam in butter schmoren
langsam sagte hanselmann am elvis
kartoffeln aber ein bisschen wenn du von
anfang an gleich mit einem starken hitze
anfängst dann sind sie außen schön braun
aber in der mitte noch roh und dazu wir
haben ja auch bei jedem gang ein fokus
produkt werde ich nämlich ein pest
sogleich noch machen mit haselnüssen
also das fest das war schon mal gehört
nämlich auch nicht schlecht ist auch die
auberginen der pfanne braten können wenn
sie schneller fertig geworden als
wolltest du es wäre zu einfach
max die schale von der technik enthält
giftige okay also ohne schutzkleidung
ist es sehr gefährlich es wird
wahrscheinlich häufig ohne
schutzkleidung gemacht weil ich so
niedrigen lohn niedrige kosten ist jetzt
natürlich auch geld es schmeckt ja auch
nur halb so gut wenn du irgendwas ist
und so erfährt dass der
menschenunwürdigen bedingungen
ausgesetzt waren während der produktion
so dann hast ja auch keinen bock mehr in
deine passion zu beißen jetzt hier in
das große team was denkt ihr wer macht
das rennen recht eindeutige ja ich werde
ich werde das machen lockt also ich muss
jetzt hier natürlich nochmal abschmecken
dies fair gehandelt ja weil man schmeckt
was da niemand darunter leiden musste
auf seine person und das gleich essen
gern basilikum pesto sieht so toll aus
dieses super grau geworden genau so
macht man das auch so aber auch gar
nicht gerade lügner der lügt leute lasst
euch nicht erzählen glaubt nur mir was
ich kann schon anrichten das jetzt
wirklich wird nicht angeben ich bin aber
auch gleich fertig so und ihren fraglich
natürlich gerade sehr schön dass jetzt
gerade gegeneinander antretet aber wer
bewertet das eigentlich dafür haben wir
eine zauberhafte jury das für uns tun
wird und ich hoffe dass ich sie
irgendwie bestechen kann oder so ich
habe ja beim einem gericht mehr auf den
geschmack geachtet und zu mir ein
bisschen irgendwie sowas zu zeigen was
cool wäre jetzt kann es noch so locker
softselect sieht besser aus als im
ganzen jahr brauchen die dinge drauf
wird das haben wir da jetzt raus
geschnitten weil so ich habe jetzt noch
ein system aber
jetzt hast du alles rausgeholt den
tellerrand muss sauber bleiben das ist
das schlimmste was du gemacht hast das
macht man nicht nein nicht so was nicht
mehr und
so max beide gerichte sind fertig dann
sieht gut aus meint sieht sehr gut aus
die jury kann kommen ja bitte da vorne
stehst du schon also gerne einmal herein
sprach hierher
[Musik]
größe peschl müsse aus dem fairen handel
wir müssen ja selbst auch noch probieren
nicht ein messer bei der diät bildet
hier sehr schlechte politik
das ist ein youtube
du sagst besser zunächst wir sehen zwar
am zweiten rang wieder
lieber max die vorspeise haben wir ganz
gut hingekriegt jetzt gehts weiter mit
dem hauptgang hauptzutat ist reis ich
mache jetzt einfach einen miesen und ich
benutze kein reis ich war sicher mein
haupt mal so ein dreistes kartoffel wir
können natürlich trotzdem vieles über
reis erzählen der nämlich zum beispiel
zu 90 prozent in asien angebaut wird
wenn reis braucht man auch sehr viel
wasser es gibt ja verschiedene bauformen
bei reise trockenen baum us anbau
brocken an bringt mit sich dass man halt
viel mit pestiziden arbeiten nur während
der nasa anbau durch die feuchtigkeit
ein bisschen besser geschützt ist
braucht aber ich glaube zwei bis 3000
liter wasser pro kilogramm reis in haiti
haben sie früher die einheimischen reis
angebaut für den einheimischen markt und
irgendwann hinter die amerikaner
gekommen und die kanadier haben gesagt
ihr müsst euer markt öffnen und dann war
es so dass der reis subventioniert war
in kanada oder auch in der usa dass der
reis in haiti der einheimische viel
teurer war als der importierte und was
haben dann die einheimischen gemacht
haben dann kein reis mehr angebaut und
dann ist die reisewirtschaft da komplett
zu grunde richtig krass ich mache einen
riesigen bogen darum reist zu kochen ich
weiß auch nicht warum ich habe irgendwie
ja steht dann ich habe sehr große angst
vor ihm ich muss mich aber auch ruhig
vielleicht mal erklären jetzt hier
gerade weil es ist wirklich so wie ich
eingangs auch meinte dass sich
vorwiegend mit rezepten immer arbeiten
hierzu komplett freestyle mit so
limitierten produkten ist wirklich eine
herausforderung für mich herr marx
herumgehen und schön die bei
restaurantketten und testen und der
menschen darauf ankommt nach essen kann
ich erklären was sie nämlich machen
möchte mit meiner sicht möchte die jetzt
quasi zu so einem schnitzel frittieren
problemen wir haben kein paniermehl das
heißt auch da muss wir improvisieren und
ich weiß nicht wie gut es funktionieren
wird normales mädel haben
schaust du drauf wenn du einkaufen gehst
ja auf jeden fall also eigentlich kannst
du ja faire produkte und bioprodukte und
so weiter und so fort kann es ja
eigentlich häufig auch mit guter
qualität gleich setzen probiere immer
bestmögliche qualität zu kaufen und bin
dann auch natürlich gerade bei so sachen
wie jetzt habe jetzt gerade verwendet so
kommst du natürlich
durch einen deckel hier theorie kein
deckel sind es karotten oder möhren die
größe entscheidet oder
aber ist es so dass die größe darüber
entscheidet wenn ich nur weiß ich nicht
da habe ich zum essen
wie weit bist du denn eigentlich bin
ganz am anfang ganz am anfang und kurz
vorm ende mit den nerven
man nennt immer was dazu jetzt habe ich
ein spitzkohl einfach hier den geschmack
hätte auch den spitzkohl aus dem
maturieren salat machen können oder es
schmoren können und deswegen ist ja
kochen so sexy so kreativ und auch so
entspannt folgen du kannst aber dann
holzlöffel rausnehmen weil weiter so
dann bitte nicht mehr aber sollte das
aromatisieren
lernt man magst du überrascht mich jetzt
immer mehr so ich könnte anrichten wie
sie bei dir aus kann ich aufgeben noch
hat die gesüßt kartoffeln raus nehmen
und in dem wasser kannst du deine morgen
koch und porsche die aberkennung wieso
das grillen und ja und dann raus niemals
um hass und dann in der butter braten du
sagst es auch wieder alles raushauen
kann sich ja auch immer wieder einsatz
her kannst du aufhören mich zu
manipulieren meine macht gar nicht dafür
bist du butter drin haben ja ich werde
butter wein machen reicht es dir auch
dabei hilft mir ich weiß jetzt so und
jetzt kannst du ja nachhaltig damit
können diese milch sogar noch einmal
nach auch die wichtiges thema ich habe
mal gehört dass teilweise den bauern für
den liter milch 20 cent nur gezahlt
werden obwohl die produktion von der
milch 45 cent kostet das mal da vorn und
hinten keinen sinn oder aber die die
supermärkte haben einfach so im monopol
dass sie den preis bestimmen können wenn
wir der mittel wählerischer wir sehen
dann werden auch die supermarktketten
auch gleich darauf reagieren politik
könnte doch da auch was machen wenn ich
zum beispiel schon verbucht und so
dumpingpreise machen gesetz rausbringen
das ist ja schon rein windows hörst
unlogisch 20 prozent abnahmen sich
steinbrück macht keinen sinn hält ich
habe schon wieder nicht so einen geilen
kontrast irgendwie wie du siehst gut aus
bei dir aber ich will da so einen klecks
drauf machen und dadurch ziehen
vielleicht weißt du das macht jedoch so
ihr könnt ja ich habe nämlich noch diese
rotweinsauce im backofen gekocht hatten
die ganze zeit jetzt nämlich keine
ahnung was ich hier machen möchte etwas
kokett
oh gott was habe ich gemacht scheiße
bist du fertig eigentlich die jury hole
ich bin fertig mit der welt gut dann
liebe jury dürft gerne kommen
[Musik]
ist die anspannung
wir haben dadurch drei richtige kennen
da ist die auberginen die geschmorte
[Musik]
vorher so berichteten
jetzt geht es weiter mit dem dessert
[Musik]
das große finale das bist du fertig ich
bin fertig und du machst mich jetzt noch
extra fertig aber wir legen ja bloß zehn
minuten perfekt als christus ja also ich
würde auch einen fehler machen aber wenn
du zehn brauchst haben wir das 19 es
basiert auf einer banane bei mir bei ihr
auch was machst du denn feindes ich
mache eine bananen kokos suppe
aromatisiert mit vanille muss auch immer
übertreiben habe 80 prozent der vanille
kommen aus madagaskar ja ich weiß halt
so was bist du bei uns auf dem markt ist
auch die 23 monate vom am baum ist es
somit auch weil sie fermentiert würden
aber vanille kann für bis zu 100 mal
einsetzen also du kannst dir ja wirklich
so kann sie mich kochen trocknen das
nächste mal wieder rein das musste ich
durch nehmen also das ist ja somit das
nachhaltigste was du kannst ihn leute
zugehen wenn du kannst sogar vanille
einfrieren das ist gut ausgleich wird
spektakulär ich weiß nicht was das ist
hypothetisch rum whisky wo es gibt
ehrlich gesagt nichts anhaben aber jetzt
gibt es muss weg ging ja ja ich muss
aber auch an ständen java vorliegen
soll das sieht aber gut aus jetzt hat
auch bestimmt schönes aroma ökumenischen
wie ist es bei dir mit kaffee trinken
kaffee ja ich liebe café
durchschnittlich bringt der deutsche den
halben mit verkraften kann weißt du was
die sektoren die von umsatz macht die
ihre mängel glaube ich schätzte kommt
meine zeit ich will jetzt mal so
schätzen einfach 200 milliarden pro jahr
zwei abgelesen diese nicht abgelesen
aber ist richtig komisch riecht schon an
so richtig
platziert hat so ganz grundsätzlich noch
einmal zum begriff fair gehandelten
verhandelt heißt bei der herstellung
soll es fair zugehen also logischerweise
steckt ja im namen es geht dabei um das
finanzielle das geht ja finanziell fair
entlohnt würde das auch natürlich aber
die ökologie das klima gerecht und fair
behandelt wird und zuletzt auch was die
menschenrechte betrifft also für uns
selbstverständlich aber leider eben
nicht bei vielen produktionsländern von
zutaten von sachen die wir jeden tag
benutzt ich weiß sie mit einer
schlagzeile machen soll wie ich die
jetzt halbwegs schöner drauf bekommen
und hat es mir vielleicht noch mal
helfen ich werde
bestimmt hatte eigentlich die ganze zeit
gerade oder japan zu helfen ist so süß
das ist stark unsere beiden des ersten
fertig wären beide viel bananen
verwendet zwei fakten zu bannen nummer
eins bei nicht fair gehandelten bananen
kriegen die erzeuger 0 7 prozent nur 7
prozent des verkaufswertes bei
vergammelten man an die verkäufer 45
prozent oder selber riesenunterschied
leben und wann sind häufiger billiger
als äpfel obwohl äpfel aus deutschland
kommen und bananen von der big band
wachsen auch in der türkei aber vor
allem müssen sie auch schmecken und das
testen wir jetzt mit unserer jury nur
kommen die nicht zu uns sondern wir
gehen jetzt an den weihnachtstisch und
präsentieren unser letztes gericht
[Musik]
die küche hat sich schon magische
aufgerollt und
max kommt hier stoßen schon mal an
während die probieren will
ich würde auf jeden fall süß glaube ich
bei uns beiden jetzt kommt ihr
entscheidung der erste gang auf jeden
fall das okay von sansibar ist frisch in
die komposition der verschiedene sachen
und das ist glaube ich gerne das war
auch wirklich super lecker ich hab's
probiert du kriegst auch meine stimme
auf
dem zweiten gang auch tatsächlich alles
ein bisschen geschmackvoller es war
schwer sich zu entscheiden tatsächlich
damit bin ich schon mal für mich
jetzt quasi dann nur noch um den
ehrenpunkt ich würde zu max nachspeise
tendieren ich mag dieses leicht
rauchiger aroma sehr gerne
es bedeutet mir genehm wirklich
dankeschön aber alle wirklich dir
nochmal herzlichen dank dass heute zu
gast war es auf dem kanal bestimmt auch
den zuschauern jede menge spaß gemacht
denn er ist auch richtig viel spaß
gemacht und ist auch klassiker wie
wirklich dankeschön es war super kurs
war spannend und danke dass wir auch ein
paar tipps gegeben hast und ihr könnt
lernen was es mit diesem pulli auf sich
hat und zwar auf ich will fair punkt.de
da steht die ganze story was alles
bedeutet hier auf diesem weihnachtsbaum
und ihr könnt ihn sogar gewinnen wenn
ihr auf ich will fair geht bei instagram
außerdem könnt ihr alle rezepte
nachkochen dann könnt ihr gesehen wie
gut es geschmeckt hat oder wie schlecht
sie vielleicht auch geschmeckt hat
deshalb danke schön nochmal an alle ich
würde sagen wir feiern hier weiter und
danke fürs zu sehen